les policiers sont confrontés tous les
jours les journalistes qui les ont
suivis bon ils ont ils ont vu ces faits
là mais c'est vrai que moi j'aimerais
bien qu'on fasse aussi un reportage sur
les jeunes qui essaient de se réaliser
de réussir leur vie
la dernière fois j'ai vu un documentaire
où il y avait des jeunes qui est faisait
des maraudes pour donner à manger voilà
des sdf
il venait de banlieue et mais
malheureusement ça ne rentrent pas dans
les réflexes primaires de bernard de la
villardière nicolas merci alors là moi
je suis par terre quand je vois tous
âges glaciaires clichés ça incroyable
entre deux et vous vivez ou pas la
violence
kallio lens avait partout alors moi pour
89 2 mois alors je suis désolé mais ce
sont les enfants qui n'ont aucune
éducation qui n'ont aucune conscience à
risque elles sont bien là mais n'ont
aucune contre moi je suis ce que vous
auriez pu imaginer non mais vous
imaginez ou pas on retrouve une arme
dans une école primaire avec des balles
mais ça veut dire que plein d'enfants
peuvent se retrouver confronté à cette
arme
aujourd'hui vous voyez bien qu'on est
dans un monde de violence l'émission de
balances ton poche c'est parce que vous
l'avez regardé hier mais pareil qui
aurait pu imaginer vous avez vu le
premier truc qui dit aux flics il leur
dit ouais on n'avait jamais mis les
menottes genre quand ni comment il lui
parlait ce que notre génération a parlé
comme ça à la police et ce qu'elle a été
aussi respectueuse et aussi un civil
mais à un moment donné regarder ce qui
se passe autour de nous enfin vous avez
des jeunes filles qui sont violées vous
avez des vous avez des enfants qui sont
agressés vous avez cette dame qui vient
sur le plateau son fils on l'a on l'a
tué
on l'a menacé pendant des mois vous
pouvez pas dire que c'est un cliché mais
renom mais alors pourquoi il ne pourrait
pas tourner mais attendez de toujours
parler des quartiers à nicolas tu peux
pas dire ce n'est pas la nuit des temps
qu'ils sont dans la violence qui sont
dans le violent et cetera c'est pas
drôle nicolas chaque génération a ses
problèmes non ça se passe dans les cas
violence inouïe ya des problèmes la nuit
etc
c'est pas aller de ligue le ballon ça va
on n'est pas concerné
des histoires de droit français rempile
problème le monde les problèmes
thiam s'est infléchie relais personnes
ses limites politiques derrière cette
émission et je peux pas laisser dire ça
parce que l'on toujours les mêmes en
fête est toujours le même qui sont
accusés c'est vrai vg pour avoir grandi
dans un quartier je suis né dans un
quartier
j'ai grandi dans un quartier je suis
encore dans un quartier dans un quartier
il n'y a pas ça ça c'est ce qu'on monte
c'est ce qu'ils veulent montrer en fait
ces acteurs aux gens qui sont à
l'extérieur des quartiers qui ne vivent
pas en quartier mois pour avoir vécu
dans un quartier et je suis encore dans
un quartier c'est tout sauf ça il l'a
dit il ya des gens qui font des maraudes
il ya plein d'associations qui se créent
actuellement pour pouvoir aider les gens
en difficulté
il ya des gens qui font des courses pour
les veillées les personnes âgées
habitent à plein de gens en fait qui est
des jeunes de quartiers qui sont là il
ya des personnes âgées ou des des mamans
de citer ou des pères de famille qui
sont là ils les aident à porter les
courses ici font plein de trucs ça c'est
ce qu'ils ont envie de montrer
voilà moi je le dis je les ai vus gelé
survécu je les ai vécu c'est un truc que
je vois tous les jours ce qu'ils
montrent eux
ok eux c'est des iguanes pas possible et
avec d une arme une arme dans une école
primaire çà s'est c'est même pour l
année réalité il y en a pleins il ya des
cons il ya des bons partout à huy et
dans les quartiers il ya surtout de bons
que de cons et les cons en général même
dans les quartiers les plus âgées du
quartier c'est les premiers à les
descendre leur disant ne fait pas ça ici
ne fais pas ça et c'est les premiers
allez allez allez allez allez allez au
même endroit